ihr habt zum Titel gelesen ich habe Dave
zu seinem Geburtstag mit einem private
Dinner überrascht und niemand geringeres
als Casper Kasper hübsch ist ja schon im
Hintergrund am werken hat schon einiges
vollbracht und ich sage euch so viel ich
freue mich riesig darauf neun Gänge aus
meiner Küche gibt es heute riesen
Überraschung und das ganze hat
angefangen vor ungefähr dreieinhalb
Stunden als Casper zu zweit hier
reingefahren kam alles erstmal
ausgeladen Sachen reingebracht und dann
ging es auch schon los wirklich perfekt
alles mit Konzept durch strukturiert mit
einem Plan quasi was muss jetzt als
erstes machen was kann als nächstes
Kasper meinte auch freuen 10 % der
Arbeit finden vor Ort statt 90 % in
Planung vorkochen sonst was bei ganz
viele Sachen sind schon vorbereitet
vorbereitet vor wie auch immer hier
stehen jetzt also wir haben vor der
Küche ihr kennt ja den großen Tisch
einiges getan damit es da wirklich eine
gemütliche Atmosphäre gibt und ich sag
so viel heute wird glaube ich für alle
die da sind und vergesslicher Abend ich
freue mich sehr darauf deshalb vielen
lieben Dank schon mal an der Stelle
Wahnsinn absolut und die große Frage die
ich mir heute Stelle ist wie gut wird
das ganze weil wenn man die Karte liest
dann denkt man nicht man sitzt bei sich
zu Hause bei sich im Büro wo auch immer
sondern halt in einem ganz ganz hohen
Gummi Restaurant darauf freue ich mich
sehr die anderen bestimmt auch jetzt
trinken wir erstmal
er meinte ich weiß doch was es ist ja
wovon hat der Maxi die letzten Jahre
immer geschwärmt das ist der
personalchest ja nicht nicht der das ist
was ganz besonderes
vergessen hast du hast Geburtstag
und ich dachte es ist viel besser als
alles was ich was ich mir vorher
ausgemalt habe
danke ja freut mich dass ihr da seid
vielen Dank danke Dir sehr gut aus
ähm ich werde nicht nur reichlich
bekocht sondern auch reichlich geschenkt
ich bin gerade umgezogen ja deswegen
gibt es von den Jungs
weiteres Material zum Einrichten
oh krank wirklich krank
[Musik]
mega geil Hammer ey vielen vielen Dank
ich wusste nicht welche Farbe und dann
mussten wir schwarz nehmen als kleinere
Farbe gehabt
normalerweise ist das hier mein Platz
Kasper du hast ihn heute anvertraut
bekommen vielen lieben Dank dass du da
bist wirklich glaub vor allem Dave was
machst du was machst du hier was wird
heute Abend abgehen ja ich bin
selbstständiger Privatkoch im Bereich
falling Sterneküche und bringe sozusagen
die Sterneküche zu den Leuten nach Hause
ja ich bereite alles vor ich komme
hierher und macht die finalen Schritte
dann vor Ort bei den Leuten in den
eigenen Küchen und das machen wir auch
heute nämlich mit neuen gängigen für den
Date und wir freuen uns schon sehr alles
ist gerichtet hammergeil wirklich was
was man hier sieht ich will nichts
vorwegnehmen ich meine wir erleben das
ganze wie jeder Gast von dir jeder
bewirte ist erleben würde einfach den
Restaurantbesuch nur ohne lästige
Anfahrt ohne alles wir sitzen bei uns zu
Hause lassen es uns gut gehen
[Musik]
ich werde dir einfach ein Bild auf den
Tisch platzieren ihr dürft sie dann ein
bisschen rumweichen ja weil sonst kommt
nicht jeder an alles ran
wir haben auch hier einmal eins
vegetarisch nicht dass das verwechselt
wird genauso wie dort drüben da haben
wir auch eins vegetarisch ich sage
nochmal erstmal vielen Dank dass ich
hier für euch heute kochen darf mit der
Katharina äh ihr dürft mich gerne Kasper
nennen wir haben uns alle schon
vorgestellt Leute sorry also das hier
bei mir aus meiner Küche immer sowas
rauskommen würde hätte ich unbedingt
gedacht also das ist schon wirklich
hammer geil wir haben jetzt das Büro rot
Garnele Saibling Lauch Hertz das ist
wieder so heile Level dass man
wahrscheinlich gar nichts checkt aber
ich freue mich sehr darauf auf dich
jetzt ist man da direkt direkt WoW und
was für mich dieses dieses Sterne Essen
immer ausmacht ist dass es nicht nach
einem Geschmack schmeckt sondern dass
ich wirklich auch für einen Laien wie
mich so die verschiedenen Facetten
wirklich einfach rausschmecken lassen
und das ist hier wieder der Fall und das
ist hammergeil das hier will ich
unbedingt probieren weil das ist einfach
Zwiebel die frittiert wurde und dann in
Form gebracht wurde sieht so hübsch aus
auch das jetzt so aus erster Hand
mitzubekommen ist so krass wenn man
checkt quasi so richtig so wie diese
Magie entstehte
das war das erklärt dass das die
Bitterstoffe regen soll den
Speichelfluss an man will mehr essen und
das ist das übertrieben gerade Hammer
WoW und jetzt hier
rot Garnelen
auch so drei komplett verschiedene
geschmacksprüche das eine ist so ein
bisschen süß was anderes super kräftig
hammergeil wirklich sehr sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr krass und jetzt bin ich schon
nicht mehr bei uns im Büro sondern
wirklich in irgendeinem richtig krassen
Sterne Restaurant beste leben
so
[Musik]
Brot mit drei verschiedenen Aufstrichen
das habe ich gelernt Sterneküche oder
gehobene Küche zeichnet sich auch durch
Brot aus durch was so einfach ist und
ich meine Nussbutter ist immer geil
tomatenbutter auch sehr gut und das hier
interessiert mich am allermeisten zur
gebräunte Butter Kapern Sardellen ich
glaube das hat richtig in sich einfach
reindippen hier am Platz
sehr sehr krass super intensiv und das
Boot ist wirklich sehr lecker schöne
Kruste offene einfache Art und Weise
außergewöhnlich mach doch einfach
Appetit auch noch mehr immer so
Kleinigkeiten die einfach reinkommen ja
immer mehr haben probier mal die
tomatenbutter die hat so man denkt okay
das ist jetzt irgendeine orangene Butter
aber probiere die mal
meiner Meinung
der hat richtig gut ne ich komme immer
wieder darauf zu dieser Kontrast so
davon dass man das zu Hause erleben kann
also ohne Zwang dieses geile Essen
unglaublich ja das gibt's eigentlich gar
nicht Hammer
[Musik]
Makrele Liebstöckel Dashi mit Konso
apfelgurke und Buchweizen klingt sehr
crazy schmeckt mit Sicherheit aus sehr
gut ich probiere das Ganze einmal und
nehme mir ein bisschen von allem Makrele
ich habe gerade eben noch zugeschaut wie
die geflammt wurde konsuel und
liebstöcke dafür also diese dieses Sud
was wir haben ein bisschen davon noch
damit
[Musik]
krank
klatschen also von links nach rechts
sondern man schmeckt alles und nichts
also schmeckt alles
[Gelächter]
sehr sehr lecker sehr voll und sehr
abwechslungsreich auch nichts was ich
woanders schon mal gegessen habe
oder ich kann für alle sprechen super
lecker super kreativ richtig geil und
wir sind erst bei Gang 3
[Musik]
was ich gerade verstanden habe ist das
das hier so ein dekonstruierter Brauhaus
Klassiker ist so Knödel Rotkohl Spinat
und Braten guten Hunger
also man braucht wirklich nur den Löffel
so das Fleisch ist so zart geschmort
wahnsinn das ist Kunst Alter boah das
ist wirklich unnormal krass das hat
genauso die Geschmacksnoten von so einem
sehr sehr außergewöhnlichen Brauhaus
ich weiß nicht was jetzt noch kommen
soll aber das war ja nur der Vorhaut
Gang jetzt kommt der eigentliche
Hauptgang ich bin sehr gespannt darauf
ich glaube Reh ist im Spiel und es wird
sehr lecker auch dass man hier einfach
mal so reinlaufen kann und einfach mal
so gucken kann wie geht's weiter was
geht hier gerade so ab ich muss sagen
bemerkenswert das ist schon wieder halb
ordentlich die Küche das war wirklich
sehr viel Spaß bisher auch draußen ist
wirklich so zwanglos alle stehen auf
wenn Sie wollen machen aber was nicht so
dieses Restaurant Feeling aber nur das
zwanghafte sondern vom Essen her bis zu
100 % in einem geilen Restaurant ich
kann mir auch vorstellen dass das sehr
oft der Fall ist das dann auch
irgendwann mal alle Leute um die Küche
herum stehen oder also es gibt natürlich
Leute die sind ein bisschen nerviger und
Leute wissen hier drauf aber in der
Regel ist das kein Problem und es ist
natürlich eine Sache ein bisschen
reinwachsen muss am Anfang ist aber wenn
man die 100 Sekunden bekommen
Hammer aus wir haben jetzt hier das
Hirschfilet rosa gebraten das ganze
wurde in Spice suböl noch mal
aromatisiert und arosiert dann haben wir
dazu einen brezelknödel der wird mit
Sellerie Creme garniert und eine
austernpilzcreme wir ein paar kleine
buchenpilze oder auch chemische genannt
ein bisschen Nashi Birne und eine Judy
über mehrere Tage drei Tage um genau zu
sein eingekocht wird Wildkatzen und
Halskette
[Gelächter]
Ring den ich je hatte und ich bin mir
sicher auch wenn ich bisher andere
Brezeln gegessen hätte trotzdem sehr gut
die süß sehr lecker sehr intensiv der
Hirsch hat wirklich ein sehr starken
wildgeschoss außergewöhnlich auch sehr
krass lecker lecker
[Musik]
guckt euch das an wir sind bei den
Desserts angekommen ihr habt richtig
gehört dass es noch mal eins von drei
Kaiserschmarrn mit Granny Smith
apfelsorbet sowie erstmal das klangvoll
so krass dass wir das so ein geile
saures sorry
sowieso Apfelmus auch so ein bisschen
und jetzt probiert diesen Kaiserschmarrn
Zimt dazu Granola ist krank
herzhaften Gang könnte ich jetzt
vielleicht nicht mehr jetzt geht's los
mit dem süßen ich habe hungrig geht auf
jeden Fall niemand nach Hause richtig
geil weiter geht's
[Musik]
orange Gegenspieler Prinzip wie im
Körper bei den Muskeln dazu sagen
[Musik]
in der Küche kennt das ist nicht zu süß
ist nicht einfach nur auf den
zuckerknopf gedrückt sag ich mal ja
krank
[Musik]
sagen wir testen uns hier durch
Eiskonfekt Mandarinen Tablet auf Carrot
Cake so ein Mini Google Hupf und weiße
Schokolade danach lassen wir das ganze
erstmal sacken aber ich glaube wirklich
das war ein ganz besonderer Abenteuer
mit einem ganz besonderen Menschen
das war die Überleitung jetzt gerade ne
Leute ich habe gerade die letzte Praline
den letzten Happen in meinem Mund
gesteckt und ich komme hier in die Küche
und die sauber
ich glaube das ist wirklich was zählt
oder wirklich danke dir Wahnsinn es war
so ein geiler Abend ich glaube wir
werden in echt alle nicht vergessen aber
unfassbar lecker und was voll und ganz
überzeugt Leute vielen Dank
unglaublich ich wollte was dazu sagen
aber ich glaube trotzdem das war crazy
heute und jeder der sowas mal erleben
will findet Kaspers links in der
Beschreibung unglaublich und vielen
vielen Dank
geil Alter es ist einfach sauber